how I wish I could grow a mustache so
that people would see me as cool with a
fashionable style and a furry smile the
ladies would drown in their drool oh I
wish I could grow a mustache so that
people would think me a man I'd work on
a farm have a rugged charm and probably
drive a white van I wish I could form a
mustache so that people would think I
was snappy I would keep it in trim I
would go to the gym with some hair on my
lip I'd be happy how I long and long for
a mustache so that people would think I
was smart I would hypothesize that a
mustache is wise and then show my
results in a chart I wish I could own a
mustache so that people would think me
their friend with a jolly old Tash I
would sure be a smash and a man on which
you could depend but alas I could not
grow a mustache my face is unfavorably
bare and now I've disclosed that my lip
is exposed till I can a fake mustache I
wear my mum was nice enough to get me a
set of self-adhesive mustaches for
Valentine's Day this year
why exactly well because she's the best
mom in the world ever you've just had
the almost imponderable joy of watching
Charlie is so cool like which makes you
like cool that about you but I think
this is a pretty good look